Daisy's dream of becoming a nurse became
a nightmare when covert hit all the
teacher is online we couldn't access the
libraries and yeah the course is
suddenly very different and my ability
to be able to complete work was was
not not good what was the hardest point
in the pandemic for you realizing that I
was going to have to redo the year and
yeah that
yeah I'd have to tell my parents that
I'd have to
after pandemic disruption and ongoing
strikes by lecturers many young people
have had enough
a high court judge will now decide
whether a case can be brought against a
university in court if students are
unhappy with their teaching they can
complain directly to the university and
then the higher education Ombudsman but
a hundred thousand people are now taking
legal action and UCL is the first
institution to be publicly challenged
Shannon is finishing her degree in
physiology at UCL and is also looking
for compensation we were given a kit of
like weighing scales and an origami
microscope and told to kind of week on
week do these simplified experiments I
mean one of them was making a cake
having had one year of fully in person
seeing lecturers completing practicals
going to tutorials yeah I'm going to
come out with the debt of probably more
than 40 50 000 pounds it just doesn't
seem right King's College London and UCL
say their staff worked hard to deliver
high quality education
but last year the higher education
Ombudsman received a record number of
complaints there is now plenty of
guidance for universities about the kind
of things they can do to mitigate the
impact of this on student the kind of
offers they ought to be making sometimes
that is coming down to financial
compensation and a lot of providers
universities and colleges are offering
that to students proactively with
lecturers now refusing to Mark exams
many current students aren't sure if
they'll even graduate this summer
the high Court's ruling against UCL will
likely set a precedent for all the other
universities
the pandemic may be over but student
life is far from normal
Alice Porter Sky News